sometimes you open your eyes and reality
feels like a dream you don't know what
is real what is fantasy what is true and
what is carefully fabricated where
voyagers commanding an impressive but
unstable Armada that sails towards the
unknown an unknown that is quite
inviting but also quite unpredictable
the precarious times that we created are
here to stay and we sometimes reduce
ourselves to Mere observers of an
inevitable future during such times the
collective Shadow grows bigger and it
exposes us to our own fragility Niche
famously wrote God is dead God remains
dead and we have killed him must we
ourselves not become Gods simply to
appear worthy of it we want it to become
gods and we got devoured by our own
vanity we reduced ourselves to primitive
instincts and realized that the road to
theosis is no bed of roses we cannot shy
away from this truth reality is
unknowable forever hidden behind the
veil of our assumptions preconceptions
definitions and paradigms our leaders
really try hard to do the best for us
but inevitably get lost in the
translation of what is the best for us
some people are pessimists and some
people are optimists in the end nobody
really knows what the future will bring
we are surrounded by so many promises
and so much hot air that we're tired to
even think about all this we're lost in
a mishmash of megalomania ambition and
greed all these are just projections
projections of a lack of honesty towards
the real issues that we are facing Carl
Jung said quite elegantly about
projections the following the effect of
projection is to isolate the subject
from his environment since instead of a
real relation to it there is now only an
illusory one projections change the
world into the replica of One's Own
unknown face and it makes sense we
humans are greatly disturbed by fear
anxiety and uncertainty and in seeking
to become more existential angst we
sometimes anchor ourselves to irrational
and ignorant practices that
oversectitude and stability I mentioned
before that we think that our Voyage is
smooth but it actually resembles
something like a Mad Max narrative let
me elaborate the unprecedented evolution
of Technology led to the expansion of
our growth practices in every level of
our societies we accelerated entropy and
increased the level of complexity in our
systems to the extent that we are unable
to control them we are actually running
faster than we can chasing something
abstract and incomprehensible yes we
want the Perpetual betterment of our
species yes we want to eradicate hunger
and poverty yes we want to minimize
inequality yes we want to achieve
self-transcendence but we need to take
into account that we're not omniscient
beings with benevolent mindsets we're
still greedy we're still hungry for
power we're still psychologically ill
we're still unspiritual we're still
humans if there is one thing that we
learned from evolution is that
evolutionary changes take a lot of time
we want to hack Evolution and transcend
human nature as fast as possible but
most probably this will backfire we
don't necessarily need to raise that
fast our journey could be quite smooth
instead we choose to ride mad Max's
Interceptor constantly tweaking it and
pumping it so it can maintain us on the
desert road for as long as possible that
happens because we are not sure of how
to face the unknown when facing the
unknown Panic is the first automatic
human response then comes acceptance
then comes adaptation then comes
cooperation in the face of danger our
brain switches to panic mode and we
become even more irrational than we
already are but why can't we escape this
mental prison the answer to this
question lies in the periphery of one's
Consciousness we live aimlessly breathe
mechanically and act in the surging flux
of the present tense we forget to
breathe properly and act as rational
agents instead of primitive egocentric
beings we can adapt to new realities
faster and better than we actually
expect if we take a step back and look
at the bigger picture Panic should act
only as an alarming mechanism not as a
survival mechanism survival comes
through cooperation and caring not
through panicking and despair Carl Sagan
once wrote in the course of looking
deeply within ourselves we may challenge
Notions that give Comfort before the
Terrors of the world let us challenge
these Notions now let's move to getting
a bit faster than usual we are in this
together and we can face the unknown
together we know this we just keep
forgetting it and one of the main
reasons is the current version of
capitalism that we have adopted capital
been prevailed after the Cold War and
for good reasons it is a system that
attempts to orchestrate Financial
Freedom that is predicated on their
responsibility and ambition of each
individual in theory this sounds great
but in practice there are some caveats
to consider equality of opportunity is
indeed a freedom that we all tend to
celebrate however we need to also
realize that opportunity has different
levels depending on social conditions
the conditions in poor ecosystems are
clearly less favorable than this in Rich
ecosystems regardless of the genetic
makeup of the individual this clear
handicap creates all sorts of problems
especially in highly populated areas
where the competition in the workplace
and the resource acquisition is high so
inequality becomes the norm in
capitalism and it is this inequality
that creates instability and
dissatisfaction capitalism is not a
Panacea it is a system inspired by our
own nature and this is the sad part of
the equation we think that capitalism is
the best system because we refuse to
accept that our nature could be flown we
all exist in this bubble of
egocentrismen where we think that we are
so special and disregard that our lack
of humility and empathy might be the
source of the Kalam us we experience we
need to create refugees of beneficial
order that deny the idea of constant
antagonism and embrace the idea of
synergy despite our differences the used
to open our minds to further
possibilities and refuse the
pseudo-comfort of passivity a passivity
that leads to a dystopic reality
dystopias exists everywhere and nowhere
they are fed by our demons and are
projected outward as physical Creations
that reflect the color of our inner
World by 2030 depression will be the
number one cause of illness worldwide
dystopias are essentially a
manifestation of our depression if you
walk in a city regardless of where you
are in the world you will notice signs
of both Utopias and dystopias whereas
dystopia has one meaning bad place
Utopia can mean both good place and no
place in other words Utopia can be
something ideal and reachable but it can
also be something unattainable and
non-existent like a far-fetched dream so
what happens here is a word play and a
perception play language is used as a
way to interpret the world and because
this interpretation has many faces we
play with words in order to ensure the
plurality of present and future
possibilities in any case dystopians and
Utopias constitute points of view even
in the most idyllic Place humans can
find reasons to complain even in the
midst of chaos humans can maintain
Stillness and peace of mind the fact is
that entropy will keep increasing and we
need to be constantly aware of this the
more entropy increases the more we lose
track of what is going on at a macro
level that is a sign that we need to
bring ourselves back to our own level of
influence when we operate in our own
level of influence we can overcome most
of our fears even the fear of death
meditating on the fear of death is quite
a bizarre mental challenge because it's
not so much about the fear of death
itself for death is a state of
nothingness which as far as we know has
no connection to our current state of
being it is more about fear of the
unknown which is a perpetual
throughout life and it is this
perpetuity that creates States like
existential angst and general anxiety
disorders anxiety is disturbing because
it is free-floating it is not like fear
fear is quite specific specificity can
be tackled because we narrow our Focus
to something that is within our scope of
understanding anxiety emerges from The
unquenchable Thirst that is individuated
human life along with the unremitting
oscillation between pain and boredom
Memento Mori is inescapable but it can
also lead to the emancipation of the
spirit slow the Mind down because the
fear is about projections of future
events narrow your perception to a
singular point of focus a singular point
of focus that is now
[Music]
thank you